hi there Steve Kaufman the 90 day
challenge continues I'm kind of slacking
off a bit i have to admit but we're off
to vancouver island today i'll be on the
ferry for an hour and 45 minutes and i
will be antisocial won't talk to my wife
nor my son and daughter-in-law i will
just study Korean because I'm onto
something very interesting oh and by the
way I'm going to speak in Russian when i
finished my few introductory comments
however the podcast quinones podcast
which I often found very difficult I've
now got a lesson it's number 22 at our
librarian link where he's talking about
the whole issue of France kefka's
inheritance and so he's gone now for
quite a while without actually reading
from literature from the book itself
which I find very difficult when he's
talking about the events that surround
friend and Franz Kafka's inheritance and
you'll have to google to find out what
it was all about I can follow it and
it's interesting of course I visited
Prague and what's interesting in all of
this is that Kafka wrote in German lived
in Prague I'm reading about it in Korean
it's all very interesting so many of the
things it's like when I studied check
and there's this totally chess communal
Asti which talks about check history but
it involves of course other parts of the
austro-hungarian Empire so there's
always this interchange and I mean even
in Russian like I'm always driven by the
interesting content I hope one day to be
able to speak the language and I know
that if I stay with interesting content
and build up my capability when I have
the opportunity to speak i'll be able to
speak as you'll be able to judge by my
Russian which I've only really had been
in Russia 12 days but I was just looking
at a part of my CD library I have about
50 russian books this is dr. Zhivago
this is a busier than yet sir which then
became this fabulous Russian Soviet
movie that Assad kosciusko pyramids you
know Tolstoy you know at sogeti master
and margarita I mean another you know
bulgakov sabes si
and this one I love when I started Putin
let's put Pushkin capitan sky OG anyway
it goes on language learning is about
the content interesting content now say
Josh ippudo gavel it pollutes key Katya
algae's Casa La Mina azucena yes cough
Etta Etta solder janya nakajima study
tresna stubbe die patata is charged
music epitome Jusik my mojo mousse notch
Oh naga naga Borgia vada nap linear use
ruski a sec Etta achieve it nuh Adam is
some a Bosniak off mera pata mo touch
kiss rana colita swallow da kotori a
gavel a piroshki e press trans twice
Batista more a chair nemore a doe TV o
Canada pay Tom oh yah Magoo petition
sweat vattam a groom may pass trance
track he absolutely is lewd me bait mo
kanina ETA ETA ETA ochin bal shy coquet
casa em provide messages polski vo pray
in mexico para para nuestra / mo sista y
no [ __ ] savoia chi thao is lucio
lumina yes no pedi shot ya posmotri me
no es policía kini piroshki young evo
pachita no budeau nidaros e a groom
Nikola Tesla audio CD CD nah premier
Capitan scared ajka Sivaji sir say Baba
cava mastery Margaritaville dracula at
sea Yeti play Sarah sonata estoy a be
spreadin it'sa Etta will my puree salve
yet ski film or chi or qi lu lu
estou Kira mazda Eva Tommy dr. Gerada e
naga naga [ __ ] it lemania a tab at
creature da was not e speed which drug
equal to d Etta Etta glove night at a
glove net sell a chalice is Chaitanya is
Lucien yeah and congestion able to
village had my stubbornness Ava's ich
acta uma nabood was nauseous coverage
can use na coccidia sahaja Gabrielle
sorry to me know yes libu decision is
niall messes la mesa gracia ya budu
girls faux bois de pata most o u- east
menahga Zappa's la playa yeah yeah
Loretta Devine hasta de vis of lib
challenge stove assassin de todo se na
Christian Yeezy ki pata movies of a tan
Tanya moisten Nellie Lanza nafa mir das
Stig noche o TV show p yerevan parka
risky no Turkish Toby ya casi en buddha
park rainy Mary pass free teach Joss
Paul tratas na is Eugenia Etta's nochi
tanya is Lucia caress kovaleski ok
attibele piroshki a slurry tirez pas
Francis key da svidanya is possible